hey what's going on it's bill burn it's
time for the Monday morning podcast for
Monday March 28 2016 the year of the yak
whatever the [ __ ] it is in the Chinese
New Year I have no idea is in that new
year next next uh next month how does
that work with those people you know how
the flicky I don't I don't get it yeah I
just don't I don't understand why we're
on standard and everybody else is on
metric can we just pick one [ __ ]
calendar one unit of measurement if I go
over Europe Jesus Christ metric and then
some old guys talk anyway [ __ ] 20
stone 20 stone I mean I guess we're
still saying horsepower Jesus [ __ ]
well what size stone were you [ __ ]
freemason
your buddy in the Illuminati is that
where he's at done you a little secret
group you think you're going to make it
buying up land on the aquifers is that
what you're going to do and then what
all the robots are going to take
everything over right you fades
everybody out but uh except you and then
you you guys you guys going to be good
and then all the robots for some reason
aren't going to turn me [ __ ] movies
you need to watch before you realize
that they're eventually going to turn on
you stuck oh you made a [ __ ] robot
now with choking you off with your dick
and you deserve it
mighty glad you stayed and on around
they go those little Illuminati with
Lionel Richie you like that let me send
me this [ __ ] video the way you might
want to you might want to watch this
thing and it was basically this person
was talking about was showing how the
automobile put the horse out of business
you know which it was so funny me like
the horse was upset like oh [ __ ] you
mean human beings aren't going to ride
on my back anymore god what do I got to
do I can't run free on the plane I guess
the horse population dropped off but
like nobody who was known you know most
of them are born into I can't really
don't see horses running around do you
aim down Wyoming yeah
see like cows at the Waffle House I'm
sorry but why would you do a fetch Oh
bill this early and come on you're
better than that bill hang on a second
come on way to do this like this a
certain standard of comedy you gotta go
that low you gotta text the Broads and
fat people all at the same time that
early hey you know whatever you got to
shoot your way out of a slump it's my
second attempt to get this thing going
this is one of these times I'm recording
the podcast not because I'm feeling it
it's because I have to because I got
[ __ ] to do tomorrow so I got to kind of
knock this thing out on Easter so
anyways anybody somebody shows me this
[ __ ] thing so the guy shows how the
car put the horse out of [ __ ]
business and yeah like I said like like
the horse is upset like when you watch
those weird commercials
we're like the mr. Potato Head sneaking
off to eat potato chips there's some
sort of weird like undertones of
cannibalism going on there and it's
supposed to be adorable I don't I don't
get those commercials on any level but
told lost my train of thought oh yeah so
they were basically showing how
computers and everything being automated
is going to faze everybody out and
there's going to be this mass
unemployment that is coming like this
was [ __ ] groundbreaking thought I
mean a dummy like me has been saying
this for [ __ ] ever right and he just
kept going like oh so you're in this
industry well you're not safe either you
think you know you actually you're a
computer programmer well guess what
you're not safe either buddy just
[ __ ] relax and like he just kept
coming with that tone and at some point
I was just like what are you going to
[ __ ] shine that light in yourself if
maybe he does by the end I couldn't
listen to them what about condescending
douchebags who think they know
everything narrating over these [ __ ]
videos you know with your big dude I
called it really are is technology in
the future going to get rid of jobs yeah
I had no idea it's only been doing that
since the beginning of [ __ ] time
these [ __ ] people are just forever
forecasting that the sky is going to
fall this is the [ __ ] thing
eventually the sky will fall nobody
knows when it's going to happen
everybody's been trying to predict it
ever since that [ __ ] Nostradamus
douchebag all the way down to a [ __ ]
like me the bottom line is none of us
know what we're talking about
ah lovely Nia well get a microphone and
a plug there in the other in the closet
till the bottom line is nobody knows
when all this shit's gonna end so just
[ __ ] go enjoy yourself you know I
just feel like this [ __ ] all this
whole presidential election you get you
got one loon it's been the clutch on the
closet a top shelf you got one lunatic
on the [ __ ] left another lunatic on
the right and then you got this [ __ ]
I don't know what she is in the middle
you know she's not really in the middle
she's just more the same you know
they're gonna Whitney she just wheel her
into the White House like [ __ ]
Hannibal Lecter dozen [ __ ] masks on
she won't have to watch her awful
[ __ ] mouth you need the plug - oh I
got the plug over here let me hit pause
- listeners don't have to [ __ ] listen
to this [ __ ] and with that
the magic of the pause button we were
able to get by all that don't you wish
you had a pause button and likes Mia
I certainly do when all of a sudden
something bad was going on like you know
I was in the middle of one of my long
drawn-out stories you could do I
actually want to fast-forward when you I
felt that your listeners might need
rescuing from that it's almost enough
just bring it down you're not an
agreement into the mic here yeah don't
do that just have it just hold it down a
little more relaxed now like you never
know what the drinks man you're always
telling me how to use the microphone
yeah because you don't dunk all right
well [ __ ] use I you want to use it
that I got my own sound man yeah you do
yeah you know you sound sometimes you
sound like a well you know the little
kid answers the phone
oh how to pick up the phone you know
it's like Hello
you're like hey what you doing today do
you have a good day like yeah that's the
hardest thing ever I just was talking to
my niece and it's just like you gotta
like you can't and if you just ask them
yes or no questions mm-hmm you got to be
like what did you do today you can't be
like did you have fun today because they
won't elaborate they're just go
yes you're like oh [ __ ] I need another
question yeah they're not the greatest
conversationalist but oh they're brutal
energy huh
a brutal interview biggest that's you oh
is that why child actors are so creepy
you know like little kid because it's
like you shouldn't be able you shouldn't
be this articulate you shouldn't be able
to just like elaborate in a way because
you're a kid yeah right no it's the
combination that they talk like adults
they're making more money than you are
right and they're wearing that little
talk-show suit the whole thing and then
just feel and they just sit there and
they cross their legs like an adult does
when they do panel and I'll just be like
you know so what was it like working on
blah blah blah TV oh he was great to
work with I've been a huge fan of his
stuff like I know yeah for the last
eight years my whole life basically I
don't think I should make little kids do
interviews I feel like that I think it's
one thing for them to do movies and
stuff but I don't think they should be
doing interviews and press and stuff I
just feel like that's weird I don't
think people should talk to little kids
period like no like you seem like little
kids I don't talk to little kids like
little kids how neither do i and I think
that that is a like I think it weirds
them out after the age of four to be
like oh okay yeah so fine I just took
any like yeah you know Dicky remember
hang on
remember in Young Frankenstein when he
just goes like it is the life I've never
sit is a laugh and Frankenstein
shouldn't they look looking at him like
dude with the [ __ ] should deal Gene
Wilder you never saw that movie
walk this way you haven't touched your
food are you quoting the movie yeah bang
word you're quoting the movie Jaws
cookie haha no no like ya never seen
that when we was [ __ ] away that the
one worried about it going [ __ ] scene
yeah the wrong horse I can speak it's
okay I remember those clips but I don't
it wasn't there something going on
Frankenstein with Yahoo serious that
comedian Austria Wow well God knows I
always [ __ ] up the name it's the one
with Gene Wilder right now I think
you're right
that's that's the name of a gene Wilder
movie but wasn't there something with
Frankenstein with Yahoo serious am I
sure I don't know I don't know why
there's like a wind tunnel where you're
talking like you don't it doesn't sound
bad no because this is what you do
you're up here and then you're down here
and then you're here you're moving it
all around so what do I do you need a
steady hand on that microphone you you
don't move your hand at all I'm pretty
consistent I just I rest it like this I
rested against my chest my chesticles
okay I mailed my mail texia my
chesticles does it sound far away though
I do this yeah it does
how about that that's fine this is good
that is good all right that's right
there I just don't move and freeze for
the next 15 days well I'm probably going
to leave through and I just came in to
say hi okay well I didn't know if you
had any questions from oh that hasn't
come in yet
oh so what are you going on about
Frankenstein now I was talking about the
illumina let's [ __ ] video somebody
told me to watch was just like this
guy's just saying about technology and
robots are going to faze everybody out
and just go you know oh you're a milkman
you think you're safe check out this
[ __ ] robot and everything it's just
like yeah what about condescending
douchebags who narrate videos like they
probably already have a robot to do that
right don't think to do what I'll tell
you this to just narrate [ __ ] they
already have the [ __ ] robot lady in
the elevator or even that's just a voice
over that in summoning can lonely please
make a poster it's like a horror film
and what did you say that weird robot
lady in the elevator I wanted a [ __ ]
robot lady in the elevator [ __ ] to do
a poster for a movie with your phasing
very concerned there's an elevator
depressing she's in like every [ __ ]
elevator and it's like going up and then
when she says going down she goes going
down and she really mean it like like
your whole life is going on the [ __ ]
and I can't tell you how many people
have been in the elevator I glide like
it's so [ __ ] depressing look I know I
hate it you're not generally okay you
know it's all of us out there in the
Ramada you know open they got that
little waffle flippy thing down there
for the continental breakfast that's
Rao's stale blueberry muffins a little
bite-sized ones that
some reason give give you a what do they
call this your little muffin top
those things are like little grenades
for your gut mm-hmm for your belly you
know you pop one of those in there you
come like like Homer Simpson yeah are
you going to do this alright let's get
into the let's get into this part of it
I thought you were giving me [ __ ] no
ma'am yep it's doing that [ __ ] let's
talk about your little trashing that you
took like a cellar level Comedy Cellar
level trashing today we were out to
brunch ah mother-in-law yeah robbers and
law and like my sister-in-law and you
and me and we go out to we go out to
luncheon and you are the biggest
sweetheart you got a wonderful sense of
humor you're a cutie pie but when you
talk to the waitstaff or just in general
I still don't see it
oh and everybody that was in agreement
you have you can you put a little
mustard on it you have like a can you
get your [ __ ] together or what like how
many times do I have to ask you the
first time like when the lady came over
and she goes what did she ask you and I
were sitting down while that is fix up
yeah at a sick child while my mom and my
brother were outside waiting for my
sister so we went to get our table and
she's been hiding at USM to drink and we
both to the waters and she goes okay and
can I give you some appetizers and I
said we're just we're waiting on three
more that's all I said but you make it
seem votos like an excuse me you had
this tone of like [ __ ] why would two
people sit at a sick stuff there's
obviously more people coming you had a
little [ __ ] and there are menus and
there were menus that see there it is
and there were menus and it was totally
that's what it was the fact that there
was menus there and she didn't do the
math you just have this well what the
[ __ ] wrong with you I but I don't
think that I'm a difficult person to
serve in a restaurant would you say that
I want then thing away the way that you
do it the way that you do it it's one of
those [ __ ] zingers it's a tone so the
person like you said something nice but
there's a
in there that makes the person a step
and a half away kind of [ __ ] their head
like was she just being a [ __ ]
[ __ ] they're my life you were
accusing me of being Shady
it's basically what it was and that's
not my intention I just you do you do
know though I not shady shady is like
this on it you're saying that no no
shady as in I'm being shady the way
growing shade are you going down going
down I I don't have I definitely have a
little less patient than normal perhaps
at a restaurant this is good you
gradually did I do feel that I don't
like it when they're not on top of me
that's all and I mean it wasn't just for
me like my mom got her salad before she
got her wine and worried but got drinks
and like you know me and my brother my
sister all had mixed drinks she had wine
like her she's been the first thing that
came out and then we all get our stuff
and then she gets a salad with no wine
and I said to her and she has a line to
the one she brought over my mom stopped
salad she has one
I wasn't like my mom ordered wine and
she should have gotten that first I
don't do all that no you don't go to
that level yeah so what's the problem no
you have a [ __ ] tone I can't do it
the way that you [ __ ] do it I just I
always look at you go go Eugenia just
[ __ ] take a little off the fastball
if you just have this [ __ ] do your
Brotherhood agreed your sister agreed
what am i never say he plated the fifth
because I'm not going to get involved in
this because she does the same thing to
be honest I'm not clattering oh that's
what your brother said what mother goes
when your mother was like that that's
where she gets it from well I mean my
mom definitely has been known to write
about food she bitched about the food
and Italy the money thing ever don't
keep saying okay you know I don't know I
guess I'm just used to a sandwich that
has meat on it more meat on it that's
more meat on it no I mean I think yeah
how hard did we teach her for
complaining about people who do a lot
but then that is ragazza for two bucks
yes
portable but um no I mean my mom has a
tendency to be like this to the point
with people like that because you know
just letting them know what's it this
was a Sunday waste at this is the Easter
Sunday waste that like I said you're not
you're not getting McBride you look
relaxing waitstaff on Easter Sunday like
let me Rhea
Wow you're just so you're going in there
with that attitude now this is all this
type of [ __ ] predisposed thought and
tone the guys like these guys like me
and I spend somebody can somebody
delicious I'm sayin Easter Sunday are
going to say that I'm saying that
they're not the creme de la creme but if
you had been in this restaurant okay so
I'm not talking about you if you had
been aggressive rock you would have seen
just how it was a little off that's all
and I wasn't like throwing a temper
tantrum being demanding you have a
mandate I mean you have this [ __ ]
attitude every [ __ ] place we go when
you order you have I'm always like easy
Mia just easy just all you're going to
do just come to breaks a little I just
feel like I'm they ask me what I want
and I just tell them what I want and
what I need and I'm the thing is when
you order I think you're fine but then
it's when when everything is in chop
shops coming your way you have a way of
like can we get some more bread that's
like please like you have this
I can't that's never been a true yes I
lose my finish so you're [ __ ]
agreeing with me I agree that I have a
low patient for service that is not the
quality but I feel but it should be yeah
well here's is it yes I'm crazy I know
and if they [ __ ] with your food they're
going to [ __ ] with my food too so it
she's [ __ ] the waitstaff has an
unbelievable amount of power that you're
not really realizing to [ __ ] with your
life I realized that I was a waitress
remember I understand how it all goes
down
I just and what happened to you at that
job
you got fired and here you are you're
gonna know yeah oh yeah yeah I got fired
Oh [ __ ] right and they could never
even tell know why I got fired okay they
were like oh you told somebody that they
couldn't have iced coffee and I said oh
you told me that we don't serve I see
anymore because it's the fall and
they're like oh but you still can have
iced coffee and I'm like oh I didn't
[ __ ] know that and that was an
example of one of the reasons why they
fired me [ __ ]
it was always evolved you want a little
mud on what a mustard getting flung
around in that place you know what you
probably had the same [ __ ] add to the
same lack of patience with the people
ordering those [ __ ] bar flies
actually no you did a great job that was
one of my favorite times was first
getting a note yeah you should I work at
this place doesn't exist anymore the
Allstate cafe on yeah the west side in
New York like that I used to work the
lunchtime shift and I would come in as
the [ __ ] you know no-name Magoo
comedian right well my days are free my
phone's not ringing you come in every
day that I was working with so Q you
come in with a New York Post you come
with the paper
I loved it and you've been the same
booth and I get a burger
Oh silly it and I would say Rosa would
come by the Rose and would come down you
looked at horrible you look secure
people love to the on people you've got
you got the chef there which I just
brought that I definitely have a Shack
there because I had friends there but
restaurants are just they're weird
environment anyway that's the only place
you ever got fired from it and I
remember how hard you took that because
everybody else you've just gotten
promoted from motor promoted that's
really plank right yeah you cried so I
think maybe that's why you have that
[ __ ] attitude when you go in there
because it brings you back oh that's
ridiculous
well then I just maybe just not a nice
person now I get impatient in restaurant
I will cop to that okay fine my cops
being impatient and restaurant well do
you remember when you were away waited
waitress and people were like impatient
with you how does that make you feel she
didn't make me feel good okay so
the next time we go out do you think
maybe I'll just let you order for me
how about that making all my desk cool
and traditional just like you like that
what oh yeah I liked it when there was
defined jobs define gender role German
yeah absolutely yeah well I liked it it
made it made us a shrew to deal with
when you take me out to eat it made it a
lot easier
what do you mean the question ship came
in by the way okay one of them skin
infection my doctor somebody wrote you
about they got they were getting married
or they're engaged in their fiancee
wanted to have a little mermaid themed
wedding you had a question yeah yeah
because I got spend it to Andrew send it
to me soon to comment I mean obviously
I'm late but I just first of all I just
don't think that the real [ __ ]
question I didn't either
are you okay good I didn't think it was
real but I was like if this is real
person would really like know 28-year
old woman wants to have their fiance
dress up as who was it supposed to be
Neptune
you know because that doesn't make any
[ __ ] sense because as soon is her
fault would would be Little Mermaid
father yeah I you would be dressed up
Erik Prince Erik and the fact that you
didn't know that just prove that you
lied because a girl who's really into
Little Mermaid like I am with know that
those are the facts well maybe they're
just talking about okay here we go
bizarre 13 most bizarre and unusual
wedding themes alright here we go
look these people are dressed up like
[ __ ] monsters alright look at these
other above-trend ambiance
yeah this isn't really this is a bit for
the pie okay people can't see we're
talking yeah well we can comment on it I
you have a little faith in me stop treat
me like a waiter having your wedding at
at a department store these people got
married at t.j.maxx alright no comment
no comment okay your entire party can be
superheroes alright so here this is
getting towards
a little Neptuna Little Mermaid Little
Mermaid okay so one was dressed like
Wonder Woman the other ones dressed like
Batman how out of shape is the Batman is
the loose-fitting [ __ ] Batman suit he
looked horrible that's some [ __ ] that
you regret later he looks like old
Batman like you know when your skin
loses the elasticity Super Mario
Brothers can smash it up at your wedding
that's a wedding cake of Super Mario
Brothers wedding just show up naked okay
now is this seeing this is seeming uh
what a bunch of [ __ ] weirdos a
rollercoaster of a wedding people get
married on a roller coaster yes I could
see that jump off a bridge while you say
I do you get the metaphor Nia is there
hitting you over the head with you two
yeah uh make it so somebody has in their
wedding ring to boldly go where no man
has gone before you've seen the theme
here there's a Shrek wedding oh really
well anyway I I thought the question
said that the dad it's wrong into a
shark cage was not the dad but like the
groom was supposed to be dressed like
Neptune and that just would not make
sense unless he was all this comic-con
[ __ ] all these [ __ ] nerds try to find
middle-earth for the wedding of your
dreams Rocky Horror Picture Show and a
zombie wedding I mean it's just people
out there that think that that shit's
cool I still thought it was a bogus
question I don't [ __ ] it okay what do I
know okay I was going to tell the story
of seeing the old guy fall off the
scooter I hope he's all right
case is closed and you helped him know
what was I supposed to do is the first
person there Billy bird of the rescue
[ __ ] guy rolling down the street
blood sliding on his face before
terrible what's up
he wasn't be add raspberries he knocked
himself out he came around he's spitting
up he's pulled out little bits of teeth
and I don't know what it was horrifying
when I saw it but now I can't talk about
it without laughing because he was on a
scooter I basically I was I'm not going
to say all the information because God
forbid the people that are related to
him are listening so the [ __ ] dude
was like [ __ ] it I'll just tell the
story I didn't do anything I just
finished flying with this exploit is
[ __ ] tragic at what we know to it I
just son finished
flying right mm-hmm which everybody says
it's so [ __ ] unsafe right fly around
and look all this cool [ __ ] fly over
Silver Lake to see that they took the
water out of it I didn't realize that
and I came back I [ __ ] land you know
say goodbye to everybody and I'm driving
out you know to the real scary thing
driving down the [ __ ] Street and I
literally pull out I make a right turn
and I don't I don't drive more than 40
yards and I just see this [ __ ] guy
just this old guy takes the turn to come
onto the on the little two-lane highway
then I'm on he's on the opposite side of
the road and he like he went too fast
and I'm like a motorcycle you can't just
turn the front wheel you're going to go
down or a scooter you know I mean you
got to kind of look your way through the
turn and lean in your momentum went them
you know supposed to look through the
[ __ ] turn he he was going too fast and
he went into the [ __ ] island in the
middle well [ __ ] it
he jumped in [ __ ] curve the whole
[ __ ] scooter went up in the back he
high tide is right he just gets launched
up and [ __ ] thing and he's rolling
down the street like a [ __ ] log what
are you having so long guys people
falling down and [ __ ] hilarious he
was fine he didn't break anything just
knocked himself out he's losing because
and then he wasn't wearing a shield and
in the end he sort of he was lying on
his face so I'm going oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] isn't watching it and I [ __ ]
pull over no I made sure everybody
stopped and I got out I was like dude I
just stay there you're all right you're
all right and anyone
he wasn't saying anything his [ __ ]
raspberry on his faces pants with torn
up you really got [ __ ] attacked by a
wild animal and he's [ __ ] late I feel
terrible that this happened to him but
it's just afterwards it's just funny and
he was laying there right in like one of
his legs he had like up like he was
chilling and the other ones just shared
like that and he was like coming around
and I was like all right man I called
9:1 you fine you're fine and then this
lady shows up and she just kept going
don't move don't move okay you're okay
just don't move okay if she gets kicked
on okay and it started annoying me and I
almost started laughing like I want to
be like lady like the way you're talking
is probably worse than what the [ __ ] is
feeling right now so by then you know
like five or six people had stopped
everybody called so this ambulance shows
up like okay thank God and now he wants
to get up we just kept telling him not
to get up and the ambulance pulls up and
he just goes uh he goes is he all right
is he all right like yeah yeah he seems
to be okay you know we're not [ __ ]
doctors but he seems to be okay and he
goes alright just tell him not to move I
already have someone on this ambulance
there's another one coming and then he
gets and drives away
yeah and then we're looking down the
street we don't see any ambulance coming
we're like what the [ __ ] and finally one
a cop finally came up and this guy was
[ __ ] priceless he gets out right
[ __ ] horseshoe bald guy right he's
got the whole landing strip he just
comes out looking like Sergeant Riker
from the rookies for anybody's old and
he [ __ ] just comes walking he like
the guy for NYPD Blue the old guy showed
his ass with the mustache - the mustache
she just comes walking up and he just
walks right up to the guy Kennett frond
yeah he just walks up like his toes are
almost touching the guy's body and he
just looks down at him he goes yeah
alright the guy definitely was going
like yeah yeah I'm fine anything as I
and ambulance going to collect he just
his level of just like I mean he must
see like people would be on fire every
day yeah this guy exactly he just seems
with scooter and this guy's [ __ ] up
it's like yeah yeah alright he also
seems way too old to still be in a
patrol car but I think he's [ __ ] up
got busted down or maybe he was on his
way to some senior police [ __ ] banquet
or some [ __ ] in his lap I'm driving the
cruiser they know I'm a cop I have to
stop so once that was fine it was funny
then we just standing there waiting for
the ambulance but you know we got to get
on with that day and me and it was tall
older black dudes standing there and
he's just like they got man and I think
yeah I'm here we both got a car [ __ ]
drove away and it was really you know
wasn't too bad it wasn't too glorious it
was just a couple of raspberries in
stuff landing in heaven but it was
injuring oh yeah absolutely but it
wasn't until I got on the highway and I
started driving I started thinking about
it and I just started laughing I think
I'm just more than surprised that and
that you saw it but there is just
something just watching somebody get
[ __ ] up like that every time I was in
Griffith parking that dude came down the
hill in street clothes on a skateboard
he went down that [ __ ] what are you
serious
through this queer you hike will you
hike up to the observatory somebody was
going down yeah okay for it yeah so I
was just north where the Greek Theatre
wasn't this guy just went yeah would fly
you buy anything and I was just like oh
my god that guy is the [ __ ] like and I'm
thinking like well how is he going to
stop because this is just downhill to
get into traffic and all of a sudden his
legs start doing that or that wobbly
[ __ ] thing and I'm like no [ __ ]
way and I'm telling you this guy was
going like [ __ ] 30 hours an hour I
said he just steps off the skateboard
you always do that even one or two steps
and then you're done he was going so
fast it just like one step and it was
like who's that guy who [ __ ] jumped
30 feet in 1969 nobody ever broke it he
[ __ ] headfirst
yeah that's client it was like the
greatest son I ever saw it he landed too
and he started rolling me it when I tell
you that this guy was rolling so fast he
was like a blur he's like he would go
like hit like his elbow which would
shoot him in the area
the best is when you're not going fast
enough to keep rolling and then you just
slide in the sand like it's all the way
down a thing and I look in the
skateboard kept going and I because it's
just not moving and I was going oh my
god and he was so he started wiping out
like 50 yards away from me I swear the
guy was a quarter-mile want to get with
a [ __ ] he stopped and he was just laying
in the road not moving like I was I
think okay he hadn't he had no helmet I
get three clothes on he was like he just
came back from drinking and he just here
like this Harrison Ford like brown
leather check his [ __ ] launched
himself so I get up so I'm getting close
to it this one he's trying to set up
he knows he's laying in the middle of
the road I finally see the skateboard
hit the curb on the other side bounced
into a parked car and then he like like
crawled he tried to stand up and he
couldn't put any way to look like and he
crawled he crawled over and sat down and
by then I knew he's alright so he's
already starting to laugh I was just
don't like doing that dude while
laughing I got you alright
he goes he's like yeah bro plop and at
that point I'm trying not to laugh oh
just like do and I go that was [ __ ]
[ __ ] hardcore man I never seen a
white ball like that if I was filming
that [ __ ] if they dude
it was the most [ __ ] it was the
greatest log roll whatever the [ __ ] you
call that thing that's it was just I
know it's been I can't believe these
shoes stayed on like you know your shoes
always fly off whenever you get hit real
hard yeah
oh my god tremendous it's [ __ ]
tremendous and it's just as much as you
feel for the person it's just nothing
funnier than watching somebody [ __ ]
wipe out if they don't die and you don't
know I'm right
good god help me man anyways let me do a
little podcast redeem a for some comedy
advertising
advertising time it's advertising time I
mean you do the questions afterlife yeah
I can get right to those things if you
know it's no one you start you know
talking to me in a certain way I'm going
to ask you what you wanted for dinner
I'm starting to get hungry again
um so mom over here we go oh the
advertising will help me reach them
advertising me at God knows I can't read
out loud they don't want me to read it
well I can't read this again she have
the whole [ __ ] am I supposed to read
the whole menu I'm not doing this [ __ ]
alright look at before you do before I
guess creamy
yeah I didn't get into this business to
have a job blue apron everybody alright
you need to know how to cook not only do
you feel like you know your way around
the kitchen honey but cooking at home
means eating healthier and saving money
instead of ordering expensive takeout
again but where do you start this sounds
like it almost old-school infomercials
some of you like looking at all the pans
and look for the camera shakes their
head look I don't know where to start
you turn on a burner you [ __ ] jerk up
blue apron blue apron as you Kabat for
less than 10 bucks per meal blue apron
delivers all the fresh ingredients you
need to create home-cooked meals just
follow the easy step-by-step
instructions this is actually a cool
thing that I would I would definitely
try that can blue aprons and that's a no
oh yeah we got too much [ __ ] I'm trying
to get rid of [ __ ] I mean a bunch of way
friend hanging around yes good they let
you food in a recipe card how do you
know I haven't even finished it that's
what blue apron is we talked about how
do I know what this is you're doing the
advertising you don't know a blue apron
it they send you the ingredients and
then the rest of a sudden exact amount
you me so you don't buy too much or too
little well unless you called blue
recipes uh-huh
maybe you do want me to read it each
meal can be prepared and I'm just saying
if I was young right and I was you know
dating or anything is a great way a
let's say and tonight we're a little
blue apron we can do that Bob each meal
can be prepared in 40 minutes or less no
overwhelming trips to the grocery store
no more sad takeout
oh look at the noodles no matter how I
know they just have to [ __ ] on
everything else it's convenient why do
you have to take grocery stores down no
matter your dietary preferences blue
apron makes it a breeze to discover and
prepare dishes like I am not reading all
of these [ __ ] things please release
three three let's we'll do like a little
like Donny and Marie here I read the
first one chicken fried chicken with
what he's not a chicken fried chicken
you wrote a chicken fried steak oh
chicken fried chicken with baked sweet
potato and quick collard greens let them
go shrimp po-boy sandwiches would
Tribeca bread locked in the [ __ ] is
Tribeca bread maybe we should go to blue
Ashland calm bacon egg never it for
ourselves
steak and eggs with kimchi fried rice
that sounds good I love kimchi right now
spiced catfish with pie is tyreq style
rice and cream use a friend a Olli
Lutheran a delicious I used to be my
stripper name seared pork with spring
that's such an old joke don't turn off
the computer nope come on over come on
I like you Leah radishes and sugar snap
peas hash with ranch yogurt I haven't
heard a half of this [ __ ] one word no
radishes and sugar snap peas hash yeah I
know I got the a hash with ranch oh go
ahead
I speak the language cousin write your
own kitchen cook with ingredients that
you've never used before like watermelon
radishes Pharaoh Pharaoh Pharaoh Pharaoh
and purple potatoes I pledge with purple
potatoes only to go to the farmers
market oh yeah every Sunday a little
dirty people walking around what thirty
people you know are you talking with the
vendors no the lefties he's wrecking my
like the hippie Carlos guys all the man
bun the [ __ ] hair fallen into the
[ __ ]
kimchi the kind of places the way you
could definitely buy weed there no I
actually I don't mind the farmers market
but I hate how you have to get
or I just hate that and you got to get
there early you got to get there early
it's like do I let me just go down the
street I'll just get the poison and
recipes between 500 and 700 calories
proportioned delicious and good for you
right now you can get your first two
meals for free at blue apron calm / /
that's blue apron calm / / blue apron a
better way to cook actually I like
farmers market because if they actually
are local farmers I like to support them
but I know the corporate food has worked
its way in there you know they just take
off corporate potatoes and they just
write haney and potatoes and then it is
like me by a big I'm sticking again hey
me and potatoes only to this week means
can you believe it mmm great I read
these things HELOCs
a great group right now it's not helix
helix was that the name of the group I
don't know give me an hour oh oh
c-c-chug what are you talking to what
you want to do rock I want to rock you
you don't know that oh no it was like I
don't know what it was it's one of most
bizarre things and there were some
reason they would dress like [ __ ]
cavemen that sounds like an 80s thing oh
absolutely was in a decent Wow you know
how old I was maybe like I would I I
don't remember but you know other things
we're speaking of robots taking over
everywhere how can you ever can make a
robot do what James Brown did you can't
you can't you know what there's some
[ __ ] nerd trying to insert oppression
and pain into a robot to see if they can
give it a little bit of soul it's like
eczema yeah they start treating it worse
than the other one ex machina yeah rx
machinae or however you pronounce it
alright
telex night after night I really feel
like it - you like helix night after
night - people lay in the same body if
you say it's bed night after night -
people lay in the same bed but when it
comes time to buy a new mattress only
one gets their way until yeah the
[ __ ] top until now introducing telex
week helix helix where you can buy
mattresses online customized for both of
you for hundreds of dollars instead of
thousands
go to helix
sweet calm answer a few simple questions
based on four key preferences do you pee
the bed
by request when you jerk off or you on
the couch here you need a plastic
so-and-so mattress cover as a result
yeah that's what that's why they're so
cheap these are old mattresses of
bedwetting keep it entertaining Shelly
let's do the recipe information they
know that's not true
until now introducing helix sleep well
you can buy mattresses online customized
for both of you for hundreds of dollars
instead of thousands go to helix sleep
calm answer a few simple questions based
on four key preferences and the results
will be custom sleep a custom sleep
profile used to build you the most
comfortable mattress you'll ever sleep
on your mattress will arrive at your
door door door soaring in about a week
and shipping is 100% free and for
couples hey helix customers customize on
each side customizing each side of the
mattress personalized to lose each of
your bodies and the way you both sleep
helix customizes
customers report a 30% improvement in
overall suite quality how do you gauge
that you're asleep right when you wake
up you know whether you've had a good
night's sleep or not alright fair enough
you have a hundred nights to try it out
if you don't love it they pick it up for
free and then what do they do with it
and give you a 100% refund no questions
asked
gross and then what do you do you throw
that back into the rotation and one of
the only a couple hundred bucks right
they just lock on this side of the bed
she likes it more soft like you have a
hundred nights to try it out that's why
everyone from GQ magazine to Forbes are
all talking about helix sleep yeah yeah
George Clooney has one of these go to
helix he calm / / and get $50 off your
order that's helix pleat calm / bar
Healy sleep calm / / I like the idea of
having a mattress as tailored to both of
our size
look if you just want to sleep in a
different bed just say it all right no I
don't think so
hmm no all right Dollar Shave Club Joe
jolly shade club.com has a special offer
for new members to join today you get a
free month kit of the executive razor
when you buy a tube of dr. cabbie dr.
cabbies easy shave butter what dr.
Carver's I say car B's yeah oh it's
Carver's I've been saying car me the
whole time dr. cabbies a doctor carbs I
never noticed it
dr. Joffe shave but dr. kavak shave
butters what it's called ez shea butter
that was a little too [ __ ] Anna what
are we making here huh what are you
making here I put this on my face you
sure about that this is the first time
they've ever done something like this
and once you try dollarshaveclub.com you
become a proud member like millions of
others one reason it's because they
deliver amazing razors right to your
door for a third of the price of what
the greedy razor corporations judge that
means when you join Dollar Shave Club
you could afford your shave with a fresh
blade anytime you want one want which
feels fantastic you'll get a first-class
shave when you use the executive blade
without hurting your wallet another
reason is there dr. cavity shape but a
carver carver using it with the
executive makes the blade glide gently
for the smoothest shave ever ever dr.
Carver's shave butter isn't your average
shave cream at the unique conditioning
formula with high quality natural
greetings leaving your skin feeling
unbelievably [ __ ] smooth all right we
get it
and right now new members who buy a tube
of shave the shea butter get the
executive razor for free they've never
done this before take advantage of it
and it's only available by going to doc
dollarshaveclub.com / / that's
dollarshaveclub.com / bar Hey
Dollar Shave club's cut cost less per
yeah it's tough this stuff that's why I
[ __ ] around on them because I'm not
going to have people subjected to my
[ __ ] reading out loud though you know
it's a funny train wreck like the way I
read is like me watching that old guy
fall off the scale
Oh grandpa Oh
Grampy did you take it too fast hey
guess what my Boston Bruins did too
today did they do something that's going
to put them in the running to be in the
family Cup flannel the playoffs the
playoffs last week you know we were
[ __ ] possibly could be you know a
bunch of [ __ ] had to happen you know
basically the Rangers and the Capitals
had to keep losing or whatever and we we
could have gone past them have been in
first place in the Eastern Conference
and then we lost five in a row okay and
today we have we won our first won't be
beat Toronto Spanish and Bruins yeah it
was going to be a [ __ ] show we lost five
in a row we [ __ ] lost to San Jose
Anaheim the Kings then the ranges and
then the Panthers and the wheels will
[ __ ] coming off and then of course as
always Bergeron and Chara [ __ ] step
up you know for the UH I guess the tying
goal and then the go-ahead goal and
what's-his-face Valesky get the [ __ ]
empty netter I missed the whole game
because we were at brunch and I was
sitting there watching you looking
absolutely gorgeous treating the
waitstaff is that why you didn't want to
go tonight
yeah I didn't know I didn't want to go
because I thought your mom wanted to go
to some place where everyone was going
to go and everyone was going to show up
with their Easter hats and I was gonna
be standing out the Sun we it's going to
be a 45-minute wait you guys want to go
down the stream get some drinks and then
maybe come back we'll give you this
vibrating he where yeah I don't want to
do that not to be that no it ended up
being great ended up being great oh by
the way I haven't even talked about it
yeah I played the terrace theater last
night in Long Beach yeah the place where
Richard Pryor did the greatest stand-up
special of all time I want to thank
everyone who came on I had such a great
time but for the first 10 minutes I was
literally freaking out going like that's
where he told the white guy you know sit
your ass down you know this is where he
did my monkey died and I remember in the
end when I waved goodnight I remember
how he finished to set the woman having
the orgasm and the whole place goes nuts
and eating up to say goodnight he just
waved ah I started to watch the special
I had to stop watching it because I knew
it would [ __ ] up my set but like it is
if it is the definite
of a comic who's just in a zone he walks
out from the beginning to end it gives
me like [ __ ] goosebumps when I watch
that special to this day he's the
greatest it's not even [ __ ] close and
I got to basically stand and do stand-up
in I just can't believe I watched that
special since I was a kid and you walk
in and it looks the exact same where you
drive in is where he drove him with his
wife when they filmed the special and it
all still looks the same
and as I was walking in I was getting
like the chills and you just walk and
it's like there it is this is this is it
this is the place and it and at the end
of the show when I said good night Dean
Del Ray came out and out showed me the
spotlight went on him so it wasn't on me
and so wasn't in my eyes anymore I could
just see the spotlight hitting the tops
of everybody's head and that's the way I
saw the theater you know because they
didn't really show the crowd in that
special and it was just one of the
coolest things ever and then the night
before I worked a theater in Riverside
California that they actually debuted
Gone with the Wind the first you know
before they had the official premiere at
Mann's Chinese Theater they wanted to
make sure the sound was all right so
they just headed east and they they shot
a talent they plug in whatever they
played the movie out there and I got to
stand on those stages it was [ __ ]
tremendous and I want to thank everybody
who came out it was [ __ ] amazing
[ __ ] amazing yeah and lastly before
we get into the questions is the Lincoln
Continental all right I talked to this
you know this guy who drove us we got a
driver to take us down to Long Beach
because I was going to have a couple of
whiskey's after that you know I was
trying to be responsible so you know I
was sitting there going like you know I
like the Lincoln Continental I hope you
don't [ __ ] it up I hope they make it
[ __ ] with the Mercedes Benz you know
like let's really make this a nice car
like [ __ ] with the 7 Series BMW I want
this thing to be a nice [ __ ] car and
I was saying you'll be cool if they
actually brought back the suicide doors
and the driver was going yeah they're
doing that the top of the line one's
going to have suicide doors and I went
and I looked it up and here's a picture
of it
mmm-hmm how sick is that [ __ ] car
that's very cool where I'm going to post
this picture and it's just the concept
car and as far as I know they didn't
[ __ ] do it why wouldn't you do that
look at that look I'll [ __ ] tears in
a second [ __ ] [ __ ] ever Mia look at
that car
yeah I see no it's cool I'm looking at
hopefully you guys are just you looking
at the picture right now they even have
like the trunk comes up and now dives
forward and then the bottom kicks out
and they were [ __ ] luggage we can see
in real life they can we know what you
have to do is you have to buy the car
and then you got to take it to one of
these wizards out here and say you see
that I want you to do that one of those
gas monkey guys tell them to [ __ ] do
that to the car wait what that's one
that I saw on the bottom this is a
Lincoln yeah this is what the LED lights
and in this one the LED lights like the
Lincoln Continental their emblem also
lights up in LED lights that [ __ ]
[ __ ] that's my 2017 Lincoln Continental
to replace 2015 Lincoln MKS yeah I'm
either going to get that I'm going to
get that Dodge Ram Artiste sport like
just a 2-door no extra padding out of
that I just I'm such a Ford guy but I
just [ __ ] love the way the Dodge Ram
Hemi truck looks one of the other mm-hm
one of the other but I'm gonna get some
I probably get the old man car that's me
right you're definitely an old man oh
yeah god dammit you know I'm pretty good
I thought it was cool I get something
alright so here we go in let's say [ __ ]
the car up and then I'll be right back
to square one
there is [ __ ] guy
you are addicted for WorldStarHipHop
let's watch these videos constant who
does the funniest [ __ ] ever sickest
fights it's the funniest [ __ ] videos
and then there's all this all this rap
[ __ ] that I'm never going to [ __ ] not
see that say I'm too out of the loop and
I end up seeing like I was a guy I liked
it
Trinidad yeah 20 dead Jana James yeah
[ __ ] that guy's a genius
I don't know yeah is he's totally
different you don't think he is I am
enjoy a couple of hit songs but what I
wouldn't go that far
you didn't see the [ __ ] video where
they had the things in that either look
cool as [ __ ] ain't that and the [ __ ]
the opening time will be belly's not
like a new concept look everything's
been done you can do that to my echo I
want you treating everybody like a
[ __ ] waiter this week I'm trying to
get something a shout out who got
knocked out of a record deal you know
what I mean after you know unbelievable
only I get to criticize [ __ ] I see that
all right let's get on to the let's go
to the get to the questions here for
this week all right
daredevil dear Billy nunchucks you know
nunchucks are yes though that was it
right there that was it right there you
just asked me if I knew what nunchuck I
just that you me I can't even read out
loud I'm not judging your fun alright
last year someone recommended you to
watch daredevil I would like to
reiterate that a year later season two
is the [ __ ] The Punisher [ __ ] people up
the way he should and you actually
believe the love story tons of cool
fight scenes watch it with the whiskey
not sure if Nia would love it but this
one's this one's for you alright I'll
give it a shot alright it's really good
one of the other waters watch it let's
watch it tonight okay I'll watch it you
want to have a whisky with me sure
whiskey with old frisky over here
sorry skin infection oh the question
everybody has not been waiting for all
right dear bill I was hanging out with
this girl
and I think she gave me a quote skin
infection oh no I haven't been with
anybody else I confronted her about it
and she said she didn't have any
symptoms I am 100% sure I haven't been
with anyone else and I contracted it
from her she's acting like nothing
happened and I didn't say I got it from
her but it's still kind of weird
should I take my chances and get back
with her or move on what kind of skin
infection do you have he means FTD he
said sure I know okay
I was hanging out with this girl I mean
if you were if that was the only person
that you had slept wasn't like the last
six months and you didn't use protection
and I mean as long as you told her just
get treated and I mean that's up to you
if you want to keep banging a girl or
not but don't keep banging this girl
oh yeah probably not yeah it's rough
sushi I mean because the thing is she
could at least be like all right well
let me go get tested just in case yeah
and then you could both be tested for
everything and get treated for
everything yeah good yeah and I tell you
separate ways because how this thing
starts off it's not good he obviously
likes banging her otherwise he wouldn't
be asking the question it may not be too
many prospects on the horizon if this is
what it's come down to and then I'll
double the obvious one she's really good
at [ __ ] that she's done it a lot a
lot of people
I mean maybe mate well maybe she got on
me she got unlucky maybe she just had
the gift I don't [ __ ] know she's
right I hope whatever you got is your
erection go to the doctor get treated
use protection like don't be an idiot
stop raw doggin out here okay new girl
no new car sorry new car that was like a
Freudian slip like get a new girlfriend
get the [ __ ] out of that thing oh man
dude brutal makes you happy to be
married all right new car dear Billy
Blue Book's I'm in the market for a new
car like yourself I want to get
something used something with character
but my girlfriend thinks I'm holding on
to the past
I'm trying to be hip in my own way she
wants me to get a Passat what do you
know how much of a creepy sellout I'd
have to be to drive a Passat is not a
sexy car why would your girl want you to
get a facade that's some lame I would
want to do you notice Barry man car not
a [ __ ] Passat wait can't fall image
element of that but I also [ __ ] drive
an eight-year-old dented Prius I know
but you're I mean I'll have frugal son
of a [ __ ] yeah I think it's a little
bit different why why is it different
well you didn't tell me to get the
[ __ ] thing you know what is you know
what it is out there there's so many
[ __ ] men and women out there that
that will derail your [ __ ] dreams
away I wonder if she wants them to get a
car like up to soccer I feel like that's
a reasonable safe car because she's
trying to get you to save up for a ring
or an apartment or something yeah look
at that thing that is not oh my god
that's not all well there's my boring
ass car I've ever seen in my [ __ ]
life but that is so blind yeah Prius at
leas it's like what is that a purse ah
whatever horrible and defected Germans
made that Germans usually [ __ ] crush
it well then I'm sure it's very
efficient believe that one alone but
other than that I'm not into it I think
the bigger thing here is what happens to
a lot of people when they get into a
relationship is look there's definitely
going to be some compromises but like
when your heart's [ __ ] racing and you
want to [ __ ] do something or the
person you're with and you can see it
like this is something they want except
they have a passion switch something's
going to make him happy if you try to
[ __ ] talk him out of it
like why would you do this she wants a
ring that's why and she's trying to get
him not to spend I have to spend money
on an older car that needs repairs and
needs this is not in the other when he
could be saving for a ring I
guaran-fucking-tee it that's what you're
thinking absolutely well he gets a used
car isn't that cheaper than going on
getting a new Passat what was I'm what
do you want it I want to get something
new into a character things I'm holding
on to the path and trying to be hip in
my own way but does English have a
little like elastic car he must yeah
classic this means yes something like
that yeah
you want to get up to Sun right she want
them to get a nice cost-effective modern
ocean we're going to have a family and a
house one day a car that's what that's
about Reid even between the nine I
thought she was the dreamcatcher you
know damn catch a dreamcatcher is like
your dream and this is my dream and then
she catches it she puts in a pocket like
that James Keller
dream killer right but you got to catch
it first okay it's like an it you can't
kill it look you just decide that things
are what you want them to be but a dream
catcher is really what a dream killer is
but you have to catch it for helping
catch it before you kill it okay Annie I
live in my own little world over here
all right magma magma okay dear bill
have you heard have you heard about the
lonesome blues have you heard of magma I
just saw them in LA they definitely
sound like some sort of [ __ ] metal
band here I never heard of them but went
with a friend of mine who works in
post-production the drummer is 68 and
unreal all right I already love this
band he plays a combination of jazz and
progressive style beats tons of soul the
music is interesting and operatic he
invited his he invented his own language
and it's really out there please look
some up and give you a reaction on the
podcast well let me [ __ ] do it really
quickly we're running out of time here
let's see here what do you think do you
think you're going to like it magma
carrion Savannah I'm surprised no dude I
was I when I saw this crazy [ __ ] band
Bobby Lee Bobby Lee's brothers in it and
I went I saw this crazy [ __ ] band
like I don't I got to the show late I
can't remember the name of the band but
they were [ __ ] oh yeah somebody
tagged me in a picture you took with one
of the band members I had the best time
they had this one you have to let them
okay I had the best [ __ ] time all I
remember was their [ __ ] their closing
song was was I think the tie was like
really like trash trash trash and the
guy just was going like no no no no no
no no no no no
it was just so ridiculous it was awesome
and funny and I was just going that you
should put that on an album cover and
then have all the lyrics like written
out like no no no no no how they're
French oh yeah magma the weirdest band
in the world alright let's see we got it
alright I'm already in I kind of like it
soon I would go through that that
reminds only vibe out to this kind of
stuff you know arrives me up I used to
go Steve you used to go see oz noise
down in the village
Oh oz Noi OC Noy yeah you'd always have
like will Lee would be down there and
Keith Carlock would fit in you settle
even the same drummers look a little bit
yeah oh my god oh my god yeah I love it
they all look a little long in the tooth
actually these guys are all beat that
guy the bass player looks like the cop
that walked up to the guy in the [ __ ]
scooter
alright oh my god I love these guys I'm
done now it's beating up Oh
what's going to happen hang on I can't
leave you here here we go
Adami fast forward to not this good
dude I would just this is the evidence
when I start seeing where it gets all
[ __ ] night yeah I'm Aiman know what I
feel like if there was if we had our own
version of the Andy Warhol's factory or
something like that like a big loft base
downtown we just had a bunch of our
artist friends and assorted weirdos we
can have magma playing in the background
and it just would make a lot of fun and
weird yes you could drown out all those
[ __ ] that hang around people like
that I'm not an Andy Warhol fan on
anything love his art or you don't like
his like persona no I respect the
originality of it but I also just feel
like a lot of it was smoke and mirrors
and it was very like that hipster sort
of sort of the original original of like
that hipster [ __ ] like I'm going to
panic soup can and I could get some sort
of comment on capitalism and everything
and it's just like all right but I think
is a really a deep comment on it because
it's not moving me I don't know I mean I
like Andy Warhol I like his stuff I feel
like that was a very cool time to be in
New York City during that time I feel
like I would have loved have been a part
of that scene but um it just seemed to
me like it was a bunch of nerds trying
to be cool pretending like a lot of
hipsters to me I think there were a lot
of myths that found each other and they
created like their own little world and
they became cool because of that that's
what I think because a bunch of like you
know what a transgender people and just
like yeah coming to image of that and
matically cool what right there is
automatically cool and you just listen
to what I'm saying like there's no
[ __ ] transgender people can I explain
to you what it was to bring together all
these different kinds of people and that
was different in the early days you know
like a whole birth of interesting like
outsider perspectives and giving them
like a platform and like you're a freak
and you're cool no no I am you really
think so then like though the what is
what why can't why if I have a different
opinion you gotta [ __ ] get upset no
it's not that you have a different
opinion is that you literally didn't
even let me finish my thought before you
just hopped on that whole thing and I
interrupt I interrupt what I do
fine you're taking this way through
Susie look do I have any sort of
artistic style and look at me looks like
I'm in a Buffalo Wild Wings I'm gonna
live here in criticize [ __ ] Andy
Warhol for [ __ ] life
oh yeah I took an Elvis cover that
somebody else already created then I
painted red and blue stripes the County
Warhol could have very easily made that
poster that's the kind of stuff that he
made actually there is a poster of him
in Dhahran Shan Michel Basquiat know
kind of like somewhat my poor poster
yeah I like the kind of like Battle of
them boxing and stuff like that poster
could 100% have been what Andy Warhol
did if you were famous back in the day
that's I'm saying saying is not original
I'm saying the person that did that
perhaps it's what putting a head on
something looking the first guy that you
could foretell photo shows a whole style
to that poster which is really cool by
the way and like that it reminds me a
little bit of what Warhol might have
done that's all the time huh well when
they went to a museum though like let's
be honest I don't like them I really
don't like it look if it's a bunch of
it's the old cars if it's painting old
cars if it's painting a cars you know
there's a big debate actually our
community our automobiles works of art
and then they and they took a Ralph
Lauren's car collection and they stuck
it in one of those [ __ ] stuck-up
museums they're MoMA how where the [ __ ]
it is Museum of Natural History though I
don't think they put in the [ __ ]
rendezvous on the 5th Avenue whatever
the [ __ ] it's called every other [ __ ]
broad I dated in New York that was
always the first date like this
let's go to a museum it's like will you
stop mark stop doing this just of your
dumb does I'm trying to find of you Oh
for [ __ ] sakes let's just go out and
get a drink and see if we can deal with
each other I got to go [ __ ] sit there
and stand next to you in silent reading
[ __ ] above dinosaur bones yeah that
sounds like a lot of fun I'll meet you
there
no I don't like them I don't like one of
the worst museums I ever went to was
when we went we were in Vatican City and
we should have gone to the right just to
look at that overrated painting on the
[ __ ] ceiling we went to those
whatever can we just pause and I just
they know what I'm talking about they
know about the Sistine Chapel and though
walking at you're overrated tiling the
art that was in the Vatican like this
art that's like a hundreds of plan honey
I'll tell you what I know like this
amazing if I bought that building
torkoal [ __ ] art if I bought that
building this Chapel I would turn that
into a cigar room and I would let that
smoke go right up into that overrated do
they make it seem like it's [ __ ] huge
there's no way it took that long just
built you went in there and you look at
it for like five seconds and then you
were like ready to get a [ __ ] panini
[ __ ] me i'ma tell you take it on in
the original contractor they said hey
can you paint my ceiling yeah yeah this
will be easy
I'll have this done in like three
[ __ ] weeks [ __ ] four years later
yeah the [ __ ] the green paints on
back order you've got 20 other ceilings
he's [ __ ] working on you can't tell
me when you went through the whole
Vatican thing and you watched every
[ __ ] vestment that every goddamn Pope
wore like after a while you're like I
get it they all wore these ponchos with
a cross on it I was fascinated by it
because I love religious art okay what
about sexual assault what about it the
[ __ ] 800-pound gorilla what I may have
a little something about that in there
yeah because I kind of went yeah I would
have ruined the you well it was an art
the way they hit all those pedophiles
all those years that's an art form to be
moving all those chess pieces around
while still collecting the money and not
paying taxes what does that have to do
with the art that were talking about
being at the Vatican well if I was to
talk about a certain somebody sitcom
right now I think you would bring up
some of his offstage behavior every time
my Cosby no we're talking about [ __ ]
slappy white
the trees the ones that were painting
the [ __ ] Sistine Chapel bill no I'm
not talking about that I'm talking about
when we looked at every [ __ ] fork and
chalice that Pope John Paul the [ __ ]
58 when you go into the Sistine Chapel
which admittedly I thought was the
sixteenth chapel did you really
you don't member that we have staying
online remember I said you know what I
would do because this line is so [ __ ]
long if I lived here I would open a bar
across the street now we called the 17
chapel and you're like why would you
call it that as I clean them sixteen
Chapel to seventy chapel look at me in
your eyes narrowed and he said bill it's
the Sistine Chapel I said oh and that's
my story about Rome all righty
oh that's all you guys all right 37
years old ladies and gentlemen see ya
I'm not into that [ __ ]
okay you know okay see you then look at
you you're an angel you can't see
through my stupidity you don't have to
be into it I still love you it's you
know a good guy it's still you know what
but the reality is that there there are
certain things that are common knowledge
I really should have known that I would
think so but I bet a lot of people think
it's the sixteenth travel you know
something I don't uh I don't like I
don't get embarrassed by [ __ ] like that
you really don't know if I think I was
yeah yeah I thought it was a sixteen I
didn't know this thing and then every oh
my god fifteen it's like did anything in
there from something that you created
then shut up what do you
oh that was the Apollo 13 mission I
really you a [ __ ] astronaut did you
sit in this diner with me getting
[ __ ] eggs aren't you and then not the
farmers my was either you don't like
that the museum do you feel like there's
a pretension and people who like art and
stuff like that it's too much [ __ ]
[ __ ] it's too much
reading retrieving oh my god and just
keeps going and going and going and then
there's people whispering Shh that's
what happened to me and it's been the
Sistine Chapel when we walked in now is
just like huh oh it's kind of small
anyway Shh oh I want to put that guy's
head right through the [ __ ] wall ever
we were in a church so it's like a holy
place so he had to keep it well I would
think they want a certain level of noise
to drown out the children screams in the
basement my god they deserve it [ __ ]
them
pieces of [ __ ] yeah yeah no no Matt
coming in here move oh we go because
she's uh oh poor thing she's right there
right all right that's the podcast for
this week I'll check in on you on
Thursday
what's that oh she was sleeping okay
cool all right
she was just lately well thank you for
uh hanging out in the podcast thanks for
having me all right I'm glad you came by
I don't think those stories of people
falling off [ __ ] would have been
expunged and to me to bounce it off up
oh look who's here
the old gray bear yeah our senior dogs I
know we just realized that dogs at
senior now she's eight she's eight and a
half years old starting to get a little
bit of white in her face yeah that made
me sad and it made me happy you know she
had a rough first year and a half and
she just could [ __ ] chill and ever
since haven't you Cleo
she looks great though was she still
adorable she still our little baby no
matter what well she had to pay rent at
this point all right that's it I'll talk
to you guys on Thursday once again
seriously man thank you to everybody
that came out this weekend
those systems are scratching the shows
at Riverside in the terrace theater and
I want to thank Dean Del Rey for
crushing at both nights and that's it I
got Canada coming up later on this week
I'm going to be in Ontario I'm you know
where Ottawa and a bunch of places
think Windsor I have no idea they're all
on my website I'm bringing all Jesus oh
geez I better hit the [ __ ] treadmill
because I'm bringing [ __ ] the pride
of New Jersey Paul virzi and the
godfather of the Rose Bowl tailgate Joe
bartnik himself he's he's going to be
coming along too
and it's going to be a killer [ __ ]
show all right that's it I'll talk to
you guys later